now before we get to the meat of it I
want you to know exactly what to expect
from these videos and how to learn from
them so let's get our expectations
clear in this particular playlist which
we are currently
watching I want to tell everyone the
story of backend engineering the
philosophies behind it the big questions
and the inner workings and the
collaborations between different
components and
machines the narration will help you see
the big picture of of a production grade
back end and help you appreciate the
concepts that are abstracted by the
languages run times Frameworks and
libraries that we use every day so let's
write it down so this playlist is about
the story
and
philosophy right and this is the first
step towards being a backend engineer
with language agnostic skills right
skills which are Beyond Frameworks or or
or any particular library that you use
and work with every
day once you have the foundations clear
once you start to see the common
patterns behind every backend
application and understand the
philosophies how the dots connect
together now that is the best time to
talk about
implementations to see how all these
principles come together to create a
complete backend application
and how all of them look and work in
actual code so let's write it
down
impation and this is the point where we
have to choose our language our
ecosystem and at this point I am
planning on releasing two versions one
in nodejs and the second one in goang
since those are the two languages that I
have firsthand experience in that I work
with every day now in this phase which
will be again another
playlist we will pick each principle and
deep dive on it in that particular
language and the surrounding ecosystem
so in a way most videos of this playlist
will have an Associated implementation
specific video in the next playist right
for example in one of the principles we
will talk about databases and drivers
and migration and all the concepts
surrounding databases that backend
Engineers deal with day to-day so the
nodejs and goang playlist will have an
implementation of that where we Deep
dive on let's say postgress with the
JavaScript driver postgress JS or the
goine driver PGX and cover every single
concept around
that now in the third phase this is
where everything comes together all our
Concepts all our language specific deep
Dives all our philosophies and now here
we will build production grade projects
from end to end with all the industry
standards and best practices we will
build quite a few of these projects
which you can follow along if you want
so let's write it
down
production
level
projects right by the end of this
journey that is if you decide to take it
and if you internalized everything and
followed along with all the projects you
should be safely able to call yourself a
backend engineer and you should be able
to go out there and build real systems
systems that scale systems that start
from zero users and scale to a million
users systems that people can maintain
over a long period of time so with those
expectations let's start